Alright, alright, alright!
Let's talk business.
And I only talk business
in my business barn.
The thing about me is,
I'm a straight shooter.
And I only do business
with other straight shooters.
Oh, I assure you,
we all shoot straight here,
don't we?
[ Laughs ]
Well, I'm gonna need you
to prove it.
Not a problem.
Is there a target?
The target...
Is this 'rita glass.
All you gotta do is shoot it
off the tippy-top
of my butler's head.
One shot each.
Giddy up!
♪♪
What are you gonna do?
I missed on purpose.
♪♪
Mrs. Cowboy: Whoo!
I shouldn't be shooting guns
at butlers
just because
my co-workers are.
It's 2019.
♪♪
Goddamn it.
That hurts, huh,
scarecrow?
Unfamiliar gun.
If I had a second shot,
I totally
would have hit it.
[ Groans ]
Oh, looks like
you could use
some help there,
pretty mouth.
-Yeah.
-All you gotta do is cock it.
[ Breathing heavily ]
And squeeze the trigger
like a ripe summer peach.
It's plump and juicy.
Now squeeze it!
[ Gunshot, glass shatters ]
[ Cheering ]
Y'all are straight shooters
after all.
Looks like
we're in business.
[ Gunshot ]
Zack!
-You shot him!
-Oh, my God, he's dead!
It had to be done.
He was a whore.
It was all right when he kissed
my house guests,
but my business partners --
unh-unh.
No, ma'am.
Now we're gonna play
another little game.
A little game I like to call...
All: "Bury the butler."